all right talk to me last thing about uh
rogan neil young versus
uh versus joe rogan absolutely
hysterical that he's basically even an
ultimatum they just like get your old
ass out of here nobody's listening to
your music anyways number one podcast in
the world we ain't giving up him what's
your take on joe rogan versus neil young
in spotify's decision
yeah i mean look props to spotify but
dude you know this it shouldn't be up to
spotify we got to build something so
that with these lever points what if it
was taylor swift man nobody can answer
that question what if it was uh i don't
know like wiz khalifa or like uh little
nos x you know people who bring in real
money to spotify then it could have been
like a 50 50 decision i don't think it
should be up to anybody this is why i'm
a big supporter of the open system of
the rss feed i always will be because
when you have single points of failure
it can be a problem perhaps a spotify
for standing up obviously neil young
like sorry boomers you'll have to go
elsewhere you can put yours put it in
your cd player or whatever to listen to
neil
um but i also want to point this out
there's a there's something bigger going
on here dude neil young sold his catalog
to a big hedge fund which is owned by
blackstone and blackstone you know
there's there's some shady stuff going
on in terms of what they're invested in
and you know some people have sent me
that they're even invested in some
pharma tech now look i mean i don't know
if this has anything to do with it or
not but they spent 150 million dollars
and when you have multi-billion dollar
hedge funds i know how dirty that these
people play uh i've seen it happen when
it comes to mass censorship campaigns
these things are never organic never
there's always something more going on
here i would not be surprised given that
neil young posted the letter and he
deleted the letter was he even aware
like what was happening i think there's
a lot more going on behind the scenes